this Christmas come on guys let's do a
holiday special one youtuber this is so
exciting we need to find a modern
Christmas classic you'll discover the
meaning of the word cringe so bad
there's three of them
one man wait wasn't she justin labor how
was she standing up talking that is not
how pregnancy works one theory why is it
still called Christmas Prince he's a
king now one really stupid movie
franchise no one is even gonna watch
this episode
[Music]
hello Internet
welcome to film theory forget Christmas
today it's all about cringe miss you
know every year I'd like to do a special
holiday episode something to set the
mood for the end of the year but the
problem is so many of the iconic
Christmas mainstays are old and was
really looking for something released
this decade I wanted a modern holiday
masterpiece instead I found a Christmas
prints on the surface a Christmas prints
looks like your usual schmaltzy
sentimental Christmas hallmark movie and
that's it were you expecting them to
that sentence because there isn't one
Christmas print sees all the romantic
movie cliches in jest you know does that
strong independent American working girl
visit some vaguely European Kingdom
enter a contrived series of events ends
up marrying the rich handsome prince
Kersh mum it's a movie that your mom
would watch actually it's probably a
movie that your mom already watched
considering the series has been so
successful on Netflix that it's gotten
itself two sequels and you can bet that
we're talking about the whole Canon
universe today consider it my Christmas
gift to you after all the presents are
unwrapped and the holiday meals done
your family can settle down on the couch
to watch it seriously while you watch it
ironically and then after the movies
done blow everyone's mind with today's
theory because after watching these
three films films and heavy quotes I am
convinced that the titular Christmas
Prince actually sucks
and that the movies Loki know this in
fact they're hinting at the villain
being the right choice for the kingdom
the entire time so step aside rise of
Skywalker there's a new must-see trilogy
of movies out this holiday season
nothing brings the family together like
a bad movie
okay I'm gonna assume that none of you
watching have seen these movies since
you know here all smart people with
better things to do with your time like
watch paint dry so let me give you the
rundown
amber is an American blogger who gets
sent on an assignment to cover the
coronation of Prince Richard in the
European Kingdom of Aldo via Prince
Richard has a reputation for being
unreliable and not wanting to take the
throne which could be a big news story
that is
Princes am i a then what happens that's
exactly what you're gonna find out in
her journalistic journey to get the
inside scoop for this hot Goss amber
pretends to be the newly hired tutor for
Prince Richard's little sister princess
Emily yes that's me the tutor after a
rocky start she learns that the Royals
aren't such stuck-up people gee shock of
all shocks manages to fall in love with
the handsome rich successful Prince and
through the power of love / family /
Christmas Prince Richard finally works
up the courage to take the throne by
being coronated on Christmas Day despite
a last-minute attempt from his evil
cousin Count Simon to sabotage the
coronation and take the throne for
himself the movie acts like the ending
of the story is good because the
handsome charismatic Richard takes the
throne well as conniving cousin Simon is
thwarted but I'm here to tell you that
the opposite is true Richard our
quote-unquote good guy is actually a
terrible ruler and the kingdom of Aldo
via would have been much better off if
Simon had been King instead one of the
first hints that we get that Prince
Richard might not be cut out for life as
a king comes early on in the movie but
he's expected to give closing remarks at
a fundraiser to an orphanage and today
to continue this tradition is my beloved
son as we find out Prince Richard missed
giving a speech because it was too busy
outside playing with the orphans it's a
moment that our main character amber
finds endearing because such a big
softie and on the surface it seems like
it should be a good thing the prince
ignoring the stuck-up rich people to
hang out with the needy kids but the
thing is the entire reason for him
giving that speech in the first place
was to give the donors a heartfelt
message to open their checkbooks and
give generously to the orphanage in fact
getting to see the Prince there at that
gala is probably why most of them are
there in the first place so when he
instead shirks that responsibility to go
play with the orphans outside yeah it
might seem like he's brightening those
orphans day but in reality he's leaving
them worse off sure orphans love
snowball fights but you know what they
love more Richard food shelter having
the money so the orphanage that houses
them doesn't bankrupt and you see that's
the problem with Richard he likes the
part where he gets to be the smile
likeable relatable guy who loves riding
around on a bicycle and waving to his
adoring subjects but he's terrible at
doing the parts of his job that actually
provide for the needs of those subjects
we see this in full display in a
Christmas Prince to the Royal Wedding
where amidst all the drama of the Royal
Wedding in the merriment of Christmas
Eldo via suddenly locked in economic
turmoil and a prosperous new year in the
single year after Richard takes the
throne to become the king the country
suddenly plummets into bankruptcy
Aldo vien companies are shutting down
and people are quickly losing their jobs
I was a foreman for Daryl concrete for
25 years before we were shut down I've
lost my job as the company I worked for
my whole life was put out of business by
your new Aldo via disaster not only that
but government workers have been unpaid
it is causing union workers to go on
strike the unions are calling for a
nationwide strike in solidarity over
unpaid wages on our work programmes ah
jeez it sure does suck when your kingdom
subjects ruin the mood of the holidays
by complaining about how their
livelihoods have been destroyed by your
failed economic programme doesn't it you
would think that think that this whole
nation and economic collapse situation
would put a real damper on the festival
'days spirit for the royal family but
now Richard and his bride-to-be find
plenty of time for Christmas romance and
that's gonna find the most perfect
Christmas tree that the palace
court-yard has ever seen the only
trouble in their life is that the
nationwide strike means that Richards
sister little princess Emily can't be in
her Christmas play why did the lights go
off why is everybody leaving the stage
abacus has gone on strike in solidarity
she would have been a brilliant princess
true nominee he make it brilliant at
home thanks luckily our queen bee amber
has a solution to the strike just order
the palace staff to put on the play you
use my play to the palace house to do
this Wow it's a Christmas miracle all
made possible through the magic of scab
labor even the threat of impending war
barely gets Richard to act in the third
film a Christmas Prince the Roy
baby Richards kingdom of Aldo via must
re ratify a 600 year old treaty in order
to remain a peace with their neighboring
country penguin if they missed the
deadline to sign the treaty the two
nations suddenly return to a state of
war if it's not renewed by midnight on
Christmas Eve
Aldo BIA and Peng Lia technically a
return to a state of war now what might
merit a bit more than the usual Google
Calendar reminder 10 minutes before the
meeting hey guys you ever consider
coming up with a treaty that I don't
know doesn't expire every hundred years
when it comes to preventing war you
might want to opt for the auto renewal
option so of course the treaty goes
missing with just hours to go
you would think then that the impending
war would be cause for massive concern
from our Christmas King Richard and his
newly coordinated Queen Amber so let's
check in on them I don't need to focus
on this missing treaty no absolutely
time apparently the only thing that gets
amber to care about this isn't the
impending war but rather a vague curse
that might be put on her unborn child
should the treaty not get signed I'm not
meant to tell you this because it's
properly rubbish but a curse will befall
on the king and queen responsible for
breaking the treaty seriously a curse no
not at all concerned about a war but a
curse that someone tells you is rubbish
does in a movie franchise where there is
nothing supernatural whatsoever maybe
you didn't hear us the first time the
chunks of this being real is
infinitesimal I don't care if it's one
in a billion I'm not risking it we need
to find this treaty oh you did hear us
you just chose to ignore basic reason
cool and where's King Richard and all
this I promised I'd build a crippled man
but I found the instructions
impenetrable not only is the man
unconcerned about the impending war on
his doorstep he apparently can't even
put together freaking IKEA furniture but
now let's turn our focus to Richard's
cousin Simon the villain of the first
movie compared to Prince Richard help
Simon is not as charismatic he's not as
handsome he's not as beloved by the
people but you know what he is he's an
economics major
degree in economics from Oxford he's a
peacemaker and I have been working
diligently on economic amendments to the
treaty which should benefit both
kingdoms and he's someone who actually
wants to be the king not only does he
have the desire to take the throne
unlike Richard in that first movie he
also technically
King is the rightful person to sit on
that throne you see
midway through the first movie it's
revealed that Prince Richard was
actually adopted not even the prince
himself was aware that he was adopted
member finds the adoption paperwork
hidden in a drawer certificate a fake
certificate the world created and the
freaking adoption papers you've got a
legit Aldo Veeam birther scandal on your
hands according to Aldo vien law as an
adopted child Richard is not part of the
royal bloodline thereby making Simon
next in line to take the throne until of
course they find an old royal decree
hidden somewhere inside a Christmas
ornament find the former Kings saying
Richard is next for the throne I mean
that alone should tell you how stupid
this country is secret decrees written
and stored inside Christmas ornaments is
no basis for a system of government but
let's look at the actions of the
villainous Simon shall we in the third
movie with war on the horizon and
Richard struggling to assemble his snig
large you know who did make caring about
the whole peace treaty a priority Simon
who is working with the Penglai and
royal families attache to make
improvements to the treaty you know I
have been working diligently on economic
amendments to the treaty which should
benefit both kingdoms and we've found a
very promising solution improvements
that you know end up getting overlooked
and ignored by Richard at the end of the
movie about in that second movie with
the country on the verge of complete
bankruptcy I may have a solution to Aldo
villa's financial crisis by investing
just a fraction of what you've known
this is about getting your hands on the
kingdoms Richard cousin know you know it
Simon is there again ready to help as
just as I say I want to help listen
Richard maybe you don't want to put him
in charge but all I'm asking you is that
you hear him out maybe he has a sound
plan well I'm asking is that you hear me
out I have a sound plan give me a chance
to redeem myself nope instead Richard
ignores Simon instead taking the advice
of Lord Leopold a friend of the royal
family ignore my cousin a guy who at the
end of the movie is revealed to be the
one in charge of a massive shell
corporation scheme in short this guy is
revealed to be the mastermind causing
the economic disaster in Aldo via
whoopsie turns out Richard isn't just a
bad ruler he's also a bad judge of
character which leads us all the way
back around to the first movie the one
that labels Simon as
the villain and the one that establishes
our hero in amber as our eventual Queen
to be but again let's beyond what the
movie tells us to think and instead
objectively look at what these
characters do so what are the first
quote-unquote villainous things that
Simon does is search the room of amber
where he uncovers the hidden adoption
papers proving that Richard should not
be the king yes it's sneaky
yes it's backhanded and yes it's an
invasion of privacy but then again amber
did all the exact same things assignment
if not worse she can't really claim to
be the wronged party here because
remember this whole story begins because
she committed fraud she lied and became
the princess's tutor with the sole
intent of infiltrating the palace and
getting a juicy story to report on it's
just really lucky for these guys that
she turned out to be a gossip blogger
and not like an assassin or
international spy probably should
consider beefing up security around here
guys I've been saying that we should
update the security protocols efficient
well you in because of these lies she
spends days getting close to the royal
family getting intimate with the King to
be all under false pretenses oh and what
about Simon finding those papers in her
room what a meanie am i right wrong
amber got those papers while snooping
around the King's personal possessions
where she then finds the birth
certificate and adoption papers which
she then proceeds to hide inside her own
belongings so remind me again whose
privacy is really being invaded here
like when Amber steals the adoption
papers from the king study we're
supposed to be okay with it because
she's the main character but when Simon
suddenly takes back the documents that
she stole so he can give them back to
the royal family somehow he's suddenly
our villain he's in the wrong double
standards my friends and what does Simon
choose to do with this new information
well he brings it before L Dovie 'iz
Parliament to expose the truth he
doesn't try to extort anyone or make any
sort of backhanded deals unlike the
Queen and the late king who tried to
cover up Richards true origins in order
to prevent a scandal in the country
Simon takes legitimate legal documents
and presents them to a legitimate legal
entity the government because he thinks
that the public deserves to know
unlike amber
apparently and you can't mention it
either what are you gonna do I don't
know yet this is somebody's life we're
talking about I'm sorry amber
aren't you the one aspiring to be a
professional journalist how else am I
supposed to become a real journalist not
like this amber not by Breaking and
Entering to find legal documents calling
the legitimacy of the head of state into
question and then helping to cover it
all up just because he have a crush on
him luckily Simon is there to do Amber's
job for her he announces that he's found
documents and presents them for anyone
to see and inspect this documentation
states the Prince Richard is in fact
adopted so across these three movies not
only did Simon try to fix an outdated
war treaty try to fix his country's
economy and also managed to uncover a
plot by an American journalist to
infiltrate the royal palace but he also
uncovered a conspiracy by the late King
dating back decades sure it's rather
convenient for Simon that unearthing
this sort of information will result in
him being king but remember Richard
didn't even want the job in the first
movie
Simon was practically doing him a favor
handing Richard an uno skip card
skip Richard his king and go to someone
who actually wants the job and let's
face it the truth is that Simon is just
more qualified here unlike Richard who
after ascending to the throne puts the
country into economic crisis and almost
pushes it to the brink of war and what
does Simon get for his troubles
well he's now branded as the bad guy
he's embarrassed in the face of the
country his wife leaves him and he's
destitute I lost almost everything I had
to Sofia in the divorce so the handsome
dumb one wins the girl and the throne
and the adoration of the people while
the smart ambitious one gets ostracized
bankrupted and pushed aside for
repeatedly trying to help the citizens
of his country Merry Christmas to all
and to all a good night
but hey that's just a theory
Oh film theory and cut
[Music]
you